dans quelques mois le centre du village
d alu et le roi va retrouver une seconde
jeunesse montant de ce projet plus d'un
million et demi d'euros
un chantier rendu possible grâce à
ingénierie cet organisme a été créé il
ya tout juste cinq ans par le
département des yvelines
sa mission accompagner les communes
rurales dans leurs projets de
réhabilitation ou de construction
je crois que le pari est réussi c'est
surtout les chiffres qui nous permettent
de dire que le pari réussi puisque plus
de 90% des communes rurales ont adhéré
170 communes rurales ont adhéré les
trois établissements publics de
coopération interdépartementale qui ont
des communes rurales ont adhéré
également depuis sa création l'agencé a
répondu à plus de 700 demandes toutes
les prestations sont gratuites
le département c'est un acteur de la
cohésion sociale tout le monde le sait
mais c'est aussi un acteur de la
cohésion territoriale est aux côtés des
maires pour un projet d'école pour un
projet de rénovation de salle des fêtes
pour créer une piste cyclable
je pense que c'est la décentralisation
concrètes
l'équipe d'ingénierie été constitué au
départ de trois personnes
elle en compte 18 aujourd'hui et est
appelée à évoluer dans les prochaines
années
l'assainissement la vidéoprotection le
procès juridique le conseil financier y
aurait plein d'autres choses à faire
pour essayer de grandir de consolider
déjà des communes qui sera dé rendre
et puis d'essayer de rajouter très
probablement dans les années à venir
d'autres compétences pour être au plus
près des élus ruraux l'agencé financé à
95 % par le département les 5% restants
proviennent des cotisations des communes
adhérentes
entre 70 centimes et 1 euro par habitant